le jour où on est sorti de prison le 13
mais nous-mêmes on avait peur tellement
c'était le bordel dehors
notre invité du samedi 21 ce soir slim à
Mamou bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour vous
Slimane bonsoir dans l'histoire de 2011
restera comme l'année du printemps arabe
et les pionniers de ce mouvement sont
les blogueurs tunisiens vous êtes slim à
Mamou le plus visible d'entre eux ce qui
vous conduira directement dans les
jaunes de Ben Ali à la chute du
dictateur vous êtes libéré et nommé
secrétaire d'État à la Jeunesse pendant
quelques mois aujourd'hui vous
surveillez de très près le parti
islamiste en Harda de Facebook à la
chute des dictateurs vous nous
raconterez à 20h l'histoire de la
première Rao la première révolution
assistée par ordinateur
[Musique]
bonsoir vous êtes né à Tunis le 8
novembre 1977 par an étudiant en
médecine quelques mois après votre
naissance vos parents vont à Paris pour
finir leurs études et vous apprenez le
français et l'arabe en même temps alors
retour il s'installe à nouveau à Tunis
et il démarre une carrière à l'hôpital
public vous vous êtes à l'école Jeanne
d'Arc qui est une ancienne école de
bonne soeurs où vous suivez un
enseignement en français en 1986 votre
père acquiet un ordinateur
IBM pour vous c'est une révélation il
vous inscrit au club informatique et à
10 ans vous programmez en Basic
donc c'est pas dire cette passion
mais à l'époque il y avait rien à un jeu
avec un chat non avec un chat
alors en voyant que c'est pas une
passade votre père décide de vous offrir
un Sarah c'est le premier ordinateur
entièrement arabe pratiquement tous mes
amis et tout mes amis même dans le
mandar arabe ont commencé par ce petit
ordinateur qui a été vraiment
révolutionnaire dans le monde en 1992
c'est l'arrivée d'Internet mais les
connexions sont réservées aux
entreprises et là avec votre copain Samy
vous créez le premier réseau
informatique privé de Tunisie jusqu'à on
pouvait pas se connecter à Internet et
au reste du monde on se connectait entre
nous
on faisait chez vous et vous vous
envoyez des messages exactement
alors à l'époque Internet se limite aux
boîtes mail quelques pages Web et le
chat vous chatez de joigné quoi alors
malgré le manque du sommeil vous
décrochez votre bac mais la note est
insuffisante pour faire architecture
vous inscrivez en maths physique en fait
vous foutez rien c'est une année blanche
ça vous intéresse pas vraiment et c'est
pendant cette année sabbatique que votre
ami Sami répond à votre place à une
offre d'emploi en se faisant passer pour
vous et vous décroche un job votre
premier job dans une agence de création
de site web qui s'appelle alpha studio
vous travaillez 15 heures par jour ça
vous passionne et vous êtes payé 300
euros par mois ouais mais à l'époque ça
me gênait pas beaucoup voilà 10 ans
après donc en 2008 vous quittez Alfa
studio et vous montez votre boîte Alexis
et là vous créez votre blog à vous au
début vous exprimez au sujet du net et
puis peu à peu vous découvrez la censure
et c'est là que en prétextant un
problème technique le gouvernement
Benali va fermer YouTube en fait parce
qu'il y avait des vidéos qui
critiquaient sa femme et il a travaillé
la raison de Carthage ils ont censuré
YouTube toute la vidéo et on a internet
pour nous était encore l'année dernière
c'était du texte alors que pour le reste
du monde c'était de la vidéo alors en
2008 à Gafsa dans le sud de la Tunisie
la région des gisements de phosphate ont
lieu les premières manifs pour un
partage plus équitable des richesses en
Tunisie Benali à ce moment-là il
contrôle la presse la radio la télé
personne n'en parle sauf sur le net
absolument ce qui se diffuse en fait sur
internet à ce moment-là c'est des vidéos
qui sont tournées avec des téléphones
portables vous dites on voyait des corps
de manifestants battus à mort par des
policiers et personne ne relayait
l'information et qui était immédiatement
censuré par les appareils de censure de
Ben Ali qui sont probablement par
ailleurs fournis par les Français alors
Ben Ali à ce moment-là décide de faire
mes Facebook et là vous décidez
d'utiliser vos compétences techniques et
professionnelles pour lutter contre la
censure c'est vraiment là que ça
commence pour vous oui d'abord j'écris
sur la censure et en parallèle
j'affine les techniques de contournement
de la censure je
j'essaye de parler des meilleures
techniques et d'aider tout le monde à
contourner cette censure en 2009 c'est
les élections présidentielles vous
lancez une contre campagne sur le net et
à l'époque lorsqu'on tapait élections
Tunisie ont tombé en fait directement
sur des articles qui dénonçaient la
corruption dans le pays ont des articles
sur la torture sur ce qui se faisait les
élections fossées et tout on les a bien
pourris mais votre blog est censuré et
Ben Ali est réélu avec 90% des voix un
message clair qui donnait à chaque fois
à chaque élection ne vous trompez pas
c'est pas des vraies élections alors à
l'été 2010 vous décidez d'organiser une
manifestation mais fallait demander
l'autorisation ministère de l'Intérieur
et là en fait vous y allez mais vous
décidez de filmer votre visite au
ministère de l'Intérieur pour demander
l'autorisation et vous la diffusez sur
internet le jour d'aller au ministère de
l'Intérieur qui était le ministère de la
peur là où se passait
on a décidé de se filmer donc j'ai filmé
ce qu'on allait faire au début c'était
pour au cas où on se faisait tabasser
pour dire voilà avant après et
finalement c'est pas fait tabasser et on
a diffusé sur Internet et c'est comme ça
qu'on a commencé à être connu voilà
alors Ben Ali fait supprimer votre
compte Twitter à ce moment-là la veille
de la mamie il faut vous êtes arrêté
garde à vue et on vous oblige à
enregistrer une vidéo où vous annoncer
l'annulation de la manifestation et vous
avez un plan B c'est un Flash Mob alors
vous faites des manifestants en t-shirt
blanc qui vont surtout les terrasses des
cafés du pays et là on voit des gens qui
se font arrêter dans tout le pays sans
savoir pourquoi ouais au début c'était à
Tunis que c'était prévu et après donc on
a fait plusieurs flashmob avec partout
dans en Tunisie des gens qui
s'habillaient en blanc alors le 17
décembre 2010 à Sidi Bouzid Mohamed
Bouazizi 26 ans si mal par le feu après
la confiscation de
s'arrête et de sa balance par la police
c'est le début du printemps arabe
dans les médias traditionnels ferment
les yeux à ce moment-là à ce moment-là
je pouvais être compréhensible parce que
ça pouvait aussi passer pour un fait
divers mais sur le fait qu'il ferme les
yeux sur la manif qui a été
immédiatement déclenchée par cet
événement c'est-à-dire les gens ils sont
sortis dans la rue immédiatement et ils
ont commencé à manifester ça c'était
plus grave
les blogueurs font circuler des vidéos
de ces manifestations
Ben Ali fait couper internet et là à ce
moment-là vous transportez les infos sur
des clés USB ou filez entre vous quoi
c'est à ce moment là qu'on a découvert
que la puissance de la technologie qu'il
avait c'est à dire le mec qui pouvait
couper internet sur la ville de Sidi
bouzidou
très bien la technique parce que quand
il y a une vague de manif à Tunis en
décembre 2010 là vous descendez dans la
rue avec une caméra qui permet de
diffuser directement sur Internet oui
c'était la première fois que je faisais
ça va utiliser ces images ce qui fait
que la révolution tunisienne est enfin
relayée par les médias étrangers
victoire voilà alors là les Anonymous
vous aide en bloquant les accès au site
du gouvernement mais en vous déclarant
soutien
de ce mouvement vous faites arrêter
j'étais monsieur Anonymous en Tunisie
parce que j'en parlais tout le temps et
je suivais ce qu'il faisait et du coup
donc je me suis fait arrêter ce qui veut
dire pour nos amis téléspectateurs c'est
Anonymous c'est un groupe international
de pirates informatiques qui porte le
fameux masque blanc voilà ouais alors
sans suivre 5 jours d'interrogatoire à
la sûreté nationale le but c'est de vous
faire craquer tout simplement alors vous
êtes menotté assis sur une chaise 24
heures sur 24 ils font des mises en
scène aussi tout ça pour faire craquer
comme à l'époque du soviétisme quoi
ouais c'est très dur c'est alors j'ai eu
de la chance de pas être torturé
physiquement mais la torture
psychologique c'est un supportable ben
oui on vous fait croire que votre
famille et votre copine ont été arrêtées
que votre copine se fait violer par
trois gardiens vous devenez fou au bout
d'un moment tu penses plus qu'à une
chose c'est de comment faire pour sortir
de là comment s'est passé la dernière
nuit là c'est scénario sur scénario il
te travaille disons psychologiquement et
un moment ils te disent là c'est bon tu
peux plus rester debout il faut que tu
dormes là tu vas mourir tout de suite tu
as le droit de dormir 4h il te
descendent un niveau plus bas je
t'emmène dans une chambre il t'attache
au lit il te disent maintenant tu vas
dormir et à ce moment-là en fait tu
crois que tu vas dormir et c'est en fait
c'est la pire nuit que tu vas passer
parce que tu as les
j'arrive étant c'était presque ça c'est
ouais en fait c'est et tu entends les
gens gueuler parce que ils se font
[__]
c'est un show sans les lumières étaient
étaient c'est
et toi tu as un mec qui vient il se fait
passer pour l'un des l'un des flics et
te fait comprendre que tu vas te faire
violer ce soir là et donc tu passes les
pires 4 heures de ta vie alors le 13
janvier un des gendres de Benali vous
appelle et vous dit le président va vous
donc on était là pour rester longtemps
c'est-à-dire on commençait à s'installer
et là tu as le directeur de la prison
qui nous appelle et qui nous dit voilà
il y a peut-être une bonne nouvelle pour
vous et la bonne nouvelle c'était non
seulement quand elle est sortie mais en
plus le mec il nous disait que
il y a plus de censure sur Internet
c'est pourquoi on s'est battu pendant
deux années et
le droit de manifester est garanti c'est
ce qui va dire Ben Ali et
dans votre ange c'est ça espèce de mytho
et quand tu sors de prison vous entendez
partout les gens qui crient la vie
dégage le jour où on est sorti de prison
le 13 mais nous-mêmes on avait peur moi
c'était le bordel dehors il y avait du
feu dans la route des voitures brûlées
etc donc on revient on dit au directeur
de la prison est-ce qu'on peut rester
encore une nuit
et le mec qui nous dit
et le mec il nous dit vous croyez que
vous êtes dans un hôtel là
bravo alors le 14 janvier Ben Ali
s'enfuit en Arabie Saoudite le 17
janvier le 1er ministre vous propose le
poste de secrétaire d'État à Genève vous
acceptez ça va durer quatre mois et puis
ensuite vous retrouvez votre ville de
chef d'entreprise et votre liberté de
parole quand même vous préférez ça oui
je préfère ça largement surtout que
travailler dans ces conditions-là
surtout dans le gouvernement c'était dur
c'est-à-dire la dès le premier jour
quand les gens ont su enfin même mes
amis quand ils ont su que j'étais au
gouvernement directement critiqués ils
m'ont dit tu dis messiannes tout de
suite tu travailles pas avec ces anciens
du gouvernement et aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous surveillez le parti islamiste
totalement contre tout organisation
basée sur une religion c'est contre
tous mes principes moraux vous attendiez
à leur score
en fait je me suis complètement gouré
sur ce point là bravo vous avez dégagé
Benali
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première révolution insistée
par ordinateur je crois que c'est jamais
arrivé avant ça oui surtout que j'aime
beaucoup ce définition l'évolution a
assisté par ordinateur la plupart du
temps ils disent révolution Internet ou
révolution Facebook ou machin et les
Tunisiens ils sont pas d'accord parce
que en fait c'est parti de la rue alors
que assister par ordinateur c'est
beaucoup plus subtil c'est beaucoup
mieux merci de votre témoignage et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu